how can do you drive these guys this is
a daily opportunity for myself an hour
and a half outside of Milwaukee
Steve Bender is driving a twenty-eight
thousand pound military cargo truck
through ditches potholes rock fields
really right out here today Steve is the
senior test technician for the biggest
provider of US military ground vehicles
the Oshkosh corporation the company is
in a tight competition for a twenty
seven billion dollar contract to make
the truck that will replace that army
workhorse the Humvee the DoD has asked
for a Mine Resistant truck with more
maneuverability and Oshkosh is hoping
their new light tactical all-terrain
vehicle will fit the bill but before any
truck can be sold to the military it
must pass a rigorous certification
process Oshkosh has set up a test track
at their headquarters the track is short
only about a mile long built to
replicate the very worst off-road
conditions from anywhere in the world we
have a variety of terrain features that
allow us to put the truck through its
paces that's Gary's needle
he makes sure akaash trucks can pass the
Department of Defense's official battery
of tests
well let's talk about three features
first let's start with the grades out
here we have grades between 20 and 60
percent and we have to be able to
negotiate these grades if we go on to a
side slope where the angle of the earth
or the angle the pavement is pitched to
one side it's a measure of stability of
the vehicle the third thing that we have
out here is our vertical step climb and
this is literally a vertical wall that
we need to ascend
camera doing great Oshkosh is la TV is
one of three finalists in the running
for the 55,000 truck contract against
Lockheed Martin and AM General the
creator of the company the winner of the
new vehicle contract will be announced
next summer
you